Welcome students to
the Pharmacology of
Antibiotics. This is
Dr. Goldstein speaking.
This is a two-part
lecture and this
is the first
part. We will talk
about the penicillins
class, the beta
-lactamase inhibitors,
but we will
start with some
general information.
General information is
important to put you
into the picture, the
big picture, so that
you can see how the
pharmacology fits in.
Here are the
learning objectives
and they are the
same for both because
this really is
only one lecture.
You'll see it's
quite extensive and
the point with
these learning
objectives is that they
are interconnected.
They are part
of the whole.
It's the relationship
between pharmacokinetics
and pharmacodynamics
just to remind you
the concentration
of drug in the blood
determines the concentration
at the site of action
and that in turn
determines the effect.
You will be
able to practice
interweaving,
interleaving, interjoining
concepts when you work on
the practice questions.
I've put in red
mechanisms, mechanisms,
mechanisms,
mechanisms of action,
mechanisms of
resistance, the reason
for the various
antibacterial
spectrums, and of
course patient safety.
Patient safety is
determined by, one, the
dose and the correct
drug for the correct use
in the correct patient,
as well as being
aware of potential drug
-drug interactions and
contraindications
to use and
the patient
-specific factors.
Here's a list of the
preparation materials.
The only requirement
for me is the
practice questions. All
the rest are optional.
This video lecture
is optional if you
feel it is valuable
to you by all means. I
hope you will use it
and gain information
from it, gain learning,
gain knowledge.
And the companion
handout that I have
prepared has all the
information you need
for answering the
practice questions. It's
intended to just be
explanatory of the
concepts that are
given in this lecture.
Certainly you don't
have to memorize it.
It's there as a
resource, an optional
resource, and guided
reading questions
the same thing. It's
an optional resource
if you find it
valuable. If you don't
wish to use any of
these materials for
learning, certainly
there are textbooks,
review books, all
kinds of other sources.
I am not recommending
that you use all of
them. Just pick out
what works for you.
I've also included
suggestions on how to
learn pharmacology.
Students asked me that
over and over and over
and my recommendation
is to think about
the big picture.
Start with the big
overview and work your way
downwards from there.
In In this lecture
I have done it that
way and my goal is to
help you think it
through in a way that's
actually achievable
and helpful to you.
Here are some
links if you wish
to use them and
some study hints.
As I said, it's the
big picture overview.
you start with the
basics, look for patterns,
chunk ideas
together. That
makes the
learning smaller.
If you start by
memorizing drug names,
foreign language
as far as you're
concerned most of the
time, and then you try
and learn every
detail about each and
every drug, you're
just making a huge
burden for yourself.
Start at the top.
Basics, patterns,
chunking, and then
when you get around
to it, that's the
time to learn the
drug names and the
one or two specific
features about the
starred drugs that
I'm asking you to
memorize by name.
It's important
to be able to
use the drug
names. Say them out
loud. Make them
your friend.
When you go into your
clinical rotations,
you can't say, oh,
you know that drug
that's got a spectrum
of this and a mechanism
of that. I don't
remember the name, but
this is what they do.
No, you need to know
the drug names. Make
them your friends.
And here is why.
You will be treating
patients. In
order to treat
infection, you'll
need to know what
the likely infectious
causes are.
Now here are some
key points. I'm
not going to go
over all of these
slides. They're
key points for you.
They are to help you
get into the frame
of the antibiotics
lectures in general.
So this is
introductory material
that may help
you. Just read
through it. It isn't
for memorizing.
These are the
bacterial pathogens
that you are
going to need to
know by name
for this course.
I have organized
them according to
patterns and chunking.
I will be returning
to this slide to
demonstrate, to
illustrate, the
various spectrums of
action of each of
the drug categories.
Hopefully, when you
see them, it will
help you make a visual
picture and make the
whole learning process
easier for you.
More key points that you
need to know
and understand.
And further.
And this tree is
not for you to
memorize, certainly.
but hopefully it
will help you
organize your thinking
about the
pathogenic bacteria.
They are
organized as limbs
and branches on the tree.
You can use this
tree or not.
We will be talking
about pathogens
that actually
are residents
of the normal
human microbiota.
An interesting fact
that you don't have
to memorize is that
we harbor 10 times
more microbial cells
than human cells.
They may be symbiotic
working together with us.
They are commensals.
And most of them have
not yet been associated
with disease. But some
can cause some very
serious drug-resistant
infections. and
I've pointed to the
takeaway microbiota cause
infection when there
is a break in the
barrier and they are able
to ********* into body
sites that is not
their natural habitat.
For example, when the
intestine is penetrated,
whether it's by
trauma or disease, the
organisms can move
from the gut into past
the intestine into
the bloodstream into
the peritoneum and can
cause some very serious
even deadly infections
so the microbiota
that we will normally
be talking about in
terms of our pathogenic
organisms our skin
********* the skin,
we take the skin
infection, sorry, the
skin organisms into the
bloodstream, and that
can cause infection.
Staph and strep are
the two that I'm asking
you to remember.
Staphylococcus aureus,
Staphylococcus epidermidis,
and Streptococcus
species. There are
many more, but these
are the ones I'm
asking you to remember.
And in the
nasopharynx, there are
lots and lots of
organisms there,
commensals, symbionts.
The ones that I'm
asking you to remember
are Neisseria
meningitidis, and
as the name suggests,
it can cause
meningitis, but it
can also cause other
things like like
inner ear infection,
otitis media, and
rhinosinusitis, so
these upper
respiratory infections.
Streptococci live
there, especially the
viridin strep and
streptococcus pneumoniae.
Streptococcus
pneumoniae causes
streptococcal pneumonia
or Pneumococcus,
Staph aureus again,
Haemophilus species.
So these I have
in red because we
will be talking about
them. And there
are of course many
anaerobes around.
We're not going to
be mentioning them
to any great degree
except for the
Clostridia species.
Now on the GI tract,
mainly in the colon,
the highest microbial
density of any
human associated
microbial community.
And there, as I put
here on the slide, the
species are far too
numerous to list.
So we'll just talk
about a few of them.
In the normal
adult colon, 96
to 99% of the
resident bacteria
flora consist
of anaerobes.
Bacteroides
fragilis I have
highlighted in
red because it is
a difficult to
treat bacterium
that can infect when
it penetrates through
the intestine. And the
Clostridium species,
which we'll talk about
further in a moment.
And there are
a few there.
It's only 1% to 4%,
but we're still talking
about 1% to 4% of
billions and billions.
the enterobacteriales.
These are facultative
anaerobic rods or
bacilli. Now, when you
see facultative anaerobic,
they are categorized
as aerobes. So the
enterobacteriales
are E. coli, Klebsiella,
Proteus, Salmonella,
Shigella. These all
are gram negative and
can cause some important
gastroenteritis,
bloodstream infections,
urinary tract infections
depending on the
organism. So they
are highly relevant.
Enterococcus fecalis
and faecium also live
in the gut but these
are gram gram positive
cocci as it says
right there and we'll
talk about those
because of the serious
infections they can
cause and of course there
are lots of there of
there's a microbiome in
the genitourinary tract
of male and female
females and I put
insert in a circle here
know this, secondary
infections can arise
from antibiotic therapy.
So we're treating
an infection with
antibiotics and
that can give
rise to another
infection. So how
is this happening?
The antibiotics,
particularly antibiotics
that are broad
spectrum, pass into the
gut or pass into
the gut circulation
will naturally cause
the death of susceptible
microorganisms
in our microbiome
that are not causing
anybody any trouble.
As a result, other
organisms that are not
susceptible to the
antibiotic therapy, such
as fungi, and
Clostridioides difficile,
which is a gram
-positive obligate
anaerobe that is
present in the gut
flora of many people,
not everybody,
this organism is
not killed by nearly
all antibiotics
and as a result it
can it has an
opportunity to overgrow
when the other
bacteria are killed.
So overgrowth of
Clostridioides difficile
C difficile can cause
diarrhea so this is
called C difficile
associated diarrhea.
Pseudomembranous
colitis, which as you can
see from the word,
is a colitis. It's an
inflammation of the
colon. And in rare,
fortunately rare,
circumstances, it can
cause megacolon, which
is life-threatening.
So that's C.
difficile, secondary
infection from
antibiotic therapy. Now,
I briefly mentioned
that fungi are
not susceptible to
antibiotic therapy.
Candida is a commensal
organism, and it can
overgrow when the
surrounding bacteria are
killed, and that can
cause a vaginal yeast
infection. And not
listed here, it can also
cause something called
thrush, which I want
you to remember,
and I'll bring it up
again. Thrush is a
candidal infection in the
mouth of the oral mucosa,
and you can recognize
it by this white
coating on the tongue.
Secondary infections.
now the target is in
the bacterial cell
wall so we need to
understand the structure
of the bacterial cell
wall which is made up
of sugars called
glycans amino sugars N
-acetylglucosamine, and
N-acetylmuramic acid,
and that's represented
by these circles,
the larger circles.
And they're labeled
here NAG and NAM.
Now the other
component is a peptide,
So it's a peptidoglycan
cell wall.
And the peptides
we see are
indicated by the
small circles.
I'm bringing
you back here
to these larger circles.
NAM,
the antacetylmuramic
acid,
has peptides attached.
the NAG portion, the
N-acetylglucosamine,
does not. So that's
the basic building
block of the peptidoglycan
cell wall, the NAM
-NAG with the 5-amino
acid peptide on it.
These peptides
now cross-link.
and that's what gives
this peptidoglycan
cell wall its
strong matrix.
The peptide cross
-linking occurs
with a
transpeptidase, trans
-cross-peptidase
-peptide-ase.
We'll get into more
details on that. Because
these peptides are
small, it's a five
-peptide string on the
NAM, and when it cross
-lengths, it becomes four
each, so it's called
an oligo-peptide,
meaning it's very short.
That's the terms. looking
now at the difference
between the cell
walls of the gram
-positive and gram-negative
organisms. This is
going to come up over
and over and over. This
is really valuable
information for you to
learn. The gram-positive
has this thick cell
wall and here's the
inner plasma membrane.
Gram-negative, here's
the interplasma
membrane, have a
very thin cell wall.
Additionally,
they have an outer
membrane, indicated
right here.
Now, this structure
on each is a capsule.
Not all bacteria have
a capsule. We are
interested, when we're
talking about the
antibiotic therapy, of
this outer wall because
in order to reach the
target in the cell
wall, the transpeptidase
or PBP, it has
to be able to get
through this outer
membrane. And not all
antibiotics can do that.
Also, there is a
periplasmic space with
the gram negatives,
and a lot of enzymes
and other proteins
hang out in that space.
We don't see that with
the gram positive.
So gram positive
means the gram
stain is positive.
It shows purple.
The gram-negative do
not take a gram stain.
Therefore, they
get stained with
a different color
so that they can
be visible under
the microscope.
The classes of the beta
-lactam's antibiotics
are the penicillins,
of which
penicillin itself is
the original prototype.
Next came the
cephalosporins, next
came the carbapenems,
and at last we
have one monobactam.
So that's the
order in which they
were developed.
The penicillins
and cephalosporins
are further
categorized by their
spectrum of action.
A narrow spectrum
means only a few
organisms are affected,
are susceptible
to these drugs.
Then there's the
extended spectrum.
More organisms are
susceptible to the drugs.
And we're thinking
about the gram-negative
when we think about
extended spectrum.
Gram-negative. More
gram-negatives.
and then we have
an extra one in the
penicillins group
which is good against
pseudomonas and an extra
one in the beta-lactam
antibiotics that's
good against MRSA.
Okay we will go into
more detail with these
as we move along.
I've also included
the other cell all
active antibiotics, and
we will only be talking
about vancomycin,
a very, very important
drug, and one
that's active actually
at the level of the
cell membrane, and
that's called daptomycin.
These two will be
covered in part two.
So let's get to it.
The beta-lactams
These are analogs
of d-ala-d-ala,
and here's our
structure-activity
relationship,
relationships.
Analogs of d
-ala-d-alanane,
so these are amino acids.
If you can use your
imagination here,
here we have our beta
-lactam ring. it's
included in this
other color and these
in this sketch this
red color so that
it's highlighting
the beta-lactam ring
hence the name beta
-lactam antibiotics.
This beta-lactam
ring is essential for
activity structure
activity relationship.
Penicillins have
this ring on them.
Cephalosporins have this
ring on them. So the
point is with these
different categories of
the drugs, the ring
is slightly different,
but they all have
this beta-lactam ring.
You do not have to
memorize these structures,
but you do have to
get the point of them.
Again, the activity
is the beta
-lactam ring. They
all must have it.
I want to point
out this enzyme.
Right here it's
pointing to the enzyme.
It's called beta
-lactamase, an enzyme
that breaks the
beta-lactam ring. So
if the beta-lactam
ring is necessary
for activity and
that ring gets broken
or cleaved, will
the drug be active?
No. So this is what
we're thinking about
as one of the
resistance mechanisms.
Bacteria that produce
beta-lactamase
that cleaves that
beta-lactam ring.
Pharmacologic
properties are
the R groups that
are indicated
on all of these
structures.
You don't have to
memorize where they are.
What you just need
to understand is that
the R groups change
the properties of the
drug. So you may
say, okay, well, we
have penicillin G.
That was the first one.
And then we have a whole
list of other drugs.
What's the difference?
And the difference
is the R group. It
gives the drugs
different properties.
general pharmacokinetics
the beta laxans
it's so easy nearly
all of course not
all but nearly all
are typical of this
pharmacokinetic profile
they can be given
****** im or iv not
all of them ******,
and not all of them IM
or IV, but we can give
them oral IM or IV.
We have drugs that can
be given by all of
these different routes.
Intrasecal is not
recommended. Indeed,
it's generally
contraindicated because
it can cause severe
CNS irritation,
arachnoiditis, fatal
encephalopathy, other
things when the CNS
tissues are exposed
to high concentrations
of the drug, as
would occur with
intrathecal administration.
That means putting
it into the spine.
The drugs pretty
much stay in the body
fluids, but they're
widely distributed in
the body fluids, in
the blood, in the
interstitial fluids,
so they are effective
against all organisms
that are susceptible
to the individual
drugs that can
get to the various
extracellular spaces.
These drugs do not
cross inside cells.
They have poor
*********** of
the cerebral
spinal fluid when
it's not
inflamed. However,
inflamed cerebral
spinal fluid such
as occurs with
meningitis, excuse me,
inflamed meninges,
such as that occurs
with infection,
causes leakiness of
the blood-brain
barrier. And as a
result, the drugs can
********* into the
CSF in higher quantities
than normally,
and these are
therapeutic levels.
they do not pass
into the vitreous of
the eye they do not
pass into the the
prostate because
of one the retinal
blood retinal barriers
here the blood
prostate barriers
here and they do not
pass into phagocytic
cells or other host
cells that may be
harboring bacteria.
So think,
what is the distribution?
Stays in the
fluids, goes pretty
much everywhere
except the CNS, except
when the meninges
are inflamed.
now that said we have
a few and you can
see they're cephalosporins
because they
all start with can
********* in relatively
high levels even
when the meninges are
not inflamed so what
is this meningitis.
See how to think
about that?
They're nearly
all eliminated
through the kidney
by glomerular
filtration and secretion.
So they go through
the transporters
in the proximal tubule.
There is a group that
we will be talking
about. I keep
saying nearly all,
nearly all, nearly
all, and it's this
group that has hepatic
metabolism. I'll
go into that more
when we get there.
They generally have
a pretty short half
-life. So short
half-life stays in
body fluids. What
does that say to you?
Frequent administration.
Short half-life
stays in body fluids.
Frequent administration.
Okay, so it's so much
easier to remember the
exception, isn't it?
There's an exception.
Ceftriaxone.
There you go. This
is a very, very
important drug. It
has a star on it.
I want to emphasize
the importance
of this drug.
Beta-lactam's pharmacokinetic
pharmacodynamic
profile is T
greater than MIC,
time greater than minimum
inhibitory concentration.
the amount of time during
the dosing interval
that the serum drug
concentration stays
above the MIC is the
important thing not the
concentration well
concentration is important
of course but not in
terms of increased
bacterial killing rate the
higher the concentration
we don't get higher
rate of bacterial
killing. Of course
we have to achieve
concentrations that are
going to be therapeutic.
So time dependent,
minimal persistent
effects, and
the drugs are
generally
bactericidal. Of course
there's always an
exception to that.
We see on this figure
that But the time
below the minimum in
inventory concentration
really has to be
minimized. It has to stay
up in the therapeutic
range for basically
the highest, for basically
most of the time.
Now let's talk
about the target in
the peptidoglycan
cell wall. This is
the whole cell wall
synthesis process.
You absolutely do not
need to remember this.
It starts out
with one molecule
by molecule by
molecule in the
intracellular space
of the bacteria.
It gets to the point
where we get the
building block, the
peptidoglycan component,
and it's carried across.
It's like a ferry.
It carries it to the
other side, and there
the peptidoglycans
are joined together.
And after that, the
cross-linking occurs.
So the beta-lactams
interrupt the last
step, the cell wall
cross-linking step.
This is a close
-up view of
the process of
cross-linking.
We have our
building blocks, our
NAMNAG pentapeptide
subunits. I've
indicated this D
-ala, D-ala, two amino
acids at the end of
the pentapeptide,
the alanine that I
mentioned before.
This arrow points to
the transpeptidase.
Transpeptidase is
the type of enzyme,
and they are
commonly referred
to as penicillin
-binding proteins.
Even before the function
of this protein,
this transpeptidase,
was identified,
the penicillins were
found to bind to some
protein in the bacteria,
and therefore they
were called penicillin
-binding proteins.
So they are important,
essential for the
cross-linking step.
And if we block that,
beta-lactamases,
sorry, beta-lactams
bind the transpeptidase
to PBP, blocks the
cross-linking step.
So what happens now?
The, it's going to block
the cell wall synthesis.
It's going to, the
organism is going to
recognize that its cell
wall is not synthesizing
properly. that will
trigger the repair
team the auto license
the auto license come
out and make little
holes in order for
the peptidoglycan
synthesis step to continue
properly and this is
fine as long as there
is maybe a hole here
or there and they fix
it but with the beta
-lactam antibiotics
blocking transpeptidase.
There's widespread
inhibition of that
cell wall synthesis.
So now these
autolycens come out,
make these little
holes all over
the place, and that
can allow fluid
to rush in and
osmotic rupture.
And there are also
probably non-lytic
mechanisms involved
as well. So, recap,
bind PPP,
block cross-linking,
trigger auto-license,
osmotic rupture,
probably non-lytic
mechanisms. That's it.
This is just a
picture to help you
visualize the cross
-linked cell wall. So
you can see it's a
nice, strong matrix,
a wall, to protect
the bacterium.
Resistance,
resistance, resistance.
This is a common theme of
all antimicrobials
and cancer.
But here we're going
to limit ourselves
to the beta-lactam
resistance, acquired
resistance,
intrinsic resistance.
Acquired resistance
is the organisms
develop enzymes that
will degrade the drugs,
beta-lactamases
that cleave that
beta-lactam ring.
And this is the
major mechanism
of resistance.
For staphylococci,
so this is MSSA, which
I'll go to in more
detail. and gram
-negative bacteria, GNBs.
Everything has to have
an acronym, it seems.
Another mechanism is
to modify the target
to cause a change
in that penicillin
-binding protein with
low affinity for the
drug, which will still
be able to participate
in the synthesis
of the cell wall.
So mutations in the
transpeptidase,
the PBP genes,
that result in
low affinity
binding of the drug.
So I've indicated here
Staphylococcus MRSA now.
Methicillin-resistant
Staph aureus,
methicillin
-sensitive Staph
aureus. When we get
to that group of
drugs, I'll go
into more detail.
Other mechanism
is to reduce the
concentration of drug
at the site of action.
So, the drug can't
get to the target.
This can happen in the
gram-negative bacteria
by changes in the
porins that are
passageways through
that outer membrane.
Also, pumping it out,
efflux. So, that will
reduce the concentration
at the site of
action. And then there
are certain organisms
that are just
intrinsically resistant.
The beta-lactams
have never
been effective
against them.
If they are
intracellular, they're
obligate intracellular,
well, the
beta-lactams
can't get to them.
And atypicals, which
are either obligate
intracellular or
they don't have PBPs.
So no target.
Here's a little
mnemonic. I didn't
make it up. I got
it out of a book.
The six Ps.
Penicillinases, but
think beta-lactamases.
PBPs, porins, pumps,
***********, and
peptidoglycan. I hope
that'll help you.
Beta-lactam antibiotics
kill bacteria cells
only when they're
actively growing and
synthesizing a cell
wall. Obviously, because
that's when the
transpeptidases are busy.
Bacteria in biofilms
formed on prosthetic
devices are much less
sensitive to antibiotics
because these organisms
are able to produce
a coating that prevents
the beta-lactam
from actually accessing
them. Furthermore,
they usually are
large populations,
so they are not
growing so fast.
Don't use antibiotics
for viral infections.
Viruses do not respond
to antibiotic therapy.
Okay, so you have a
patient or a patient's
mother or father or
caregiver who says,
well i know it's a
viral infection but it
might be a bacterial
infection maybe the
maybe my family
members should have an
antibiotic just in case
just in case and it's so
tempted so tempting
to think well okay i
mean what can it hurt
well it can hurt first
of all we don't give
drugs that are not
going to be useful
it's just not right
secondly antibiotics do
have side effects we're
allowing these the
patient to be exposed
to side effects for
no reason furthermore
unnecessary antibiotic
use promotes resistance
in organisms and
finally many antibiotics
are very expensive
and not everybody
can afford them. So
this is an unnecessary
cost for the patient
or a patient's family.
Antibiotic selection
is based on the site of
the infection. Can the
drug get to the site
of infection? The
spectrums of activity. We
have to select drugs
that are going to be
effective and not all
drugs are effective
against everything. We
have to think about the
potential for microbial
resistance. In other
words, is the patient
infected with a microbe
that's going to be
resistant to the drug?
Of course, patient
factors. Is
it safe for the
patient? Can
the patient
acquire the drug?
Remember, there are
a number of pharmacy
deserts in this
country where
patients can't even
get to a pharmacy.
We have to think
about the toxicity of
the drug and the
cost to the patient.
Beta-lactams are
so, so, so useful.
I would say they are
the most frequently
used drugs for
the treatment of
bacterial infections.
But, of course,
the infections must
be susceptible.
And infections can
occur any place. I
put a list here, but
this is intuitive.
They can just
occur everywhere.
Now, our drug
selection. Well, how
do we think about
selecting the drug?
We need a drug with
activity against
the infectious
pathogen. We need
a drug that
distributes to the
site of action. It
has to get there.
At a dose that
achieves adequate
therapeutic concentration
by the appropriate
route of administration
and is not
contraindicated
in the individual
patient.
Again, intuitive.
The most important
adverse effect of
penicillins is
hypersensitivity reactions.
Now penicillins are
pretty small molecules.
I think you could
appreciate thinking about
their chemical
structure. So on their
own, they don't cause
allergic reactions.
However, penicillins,
other beta-lactams, or
their metabolites, can
cause hapten formation.
hapten. Please know
this word hapten.
Where the drug will
bind, the drug of a
metabolite, will bind
covalently to a protein,
a host protein. And
the red blood cell
membrane is typical
of the penicillin.
So protein on the red
blood cell membrane.
Now antibodies
created against this
drug protein complex
can stimulate an
immune attack, and
that can lead to
hemolytic anemia as
the red blood cells
are lysed because of
this immune attack.
So, well, okay, it's
a well-known adverse
effect of
penicillins, but what
about the potential
for cross-reactivity
with others in the
beta-lactam group.
This has been a
subject of debate
since the beginning
of all these
other groups of
beta-lactams.
What it has boiled
down to is that the
cross-reactivity potential
with cephalosporins
in particular and
other beta-lactams
is related to
structural similarities.
So structural
similarities of what? we
know they all have
a beta-lactam ring
they have other
rings well it's the
similarities of the
side chains so to
any drugs that has
a side chain that's
similar to another
beta-lactam that a
patient had an
allergic reaction to is
likely to be cross
-reactive so how do
we know sometimes
people will come in
and Say, I had an
allergic reaction to
penicillin. Well,
how did it manifest?
Well, I had a
stomachache. Well,
that's not an
allergic reaction.
It's an effective
penicillin. It
can cause a
stomachache, but
that's not an
allergic reaction.
So you need to
delve into that. And
if a person really,
really needs that
penicillin, skin
testing can be done.
And I put some statistics
here. This is for
you to get you into
the context, but you
don't have to memorize
statistics for me.
Remember,
beta-lactams are
among the leading
causes of drug
-induced anaphylaxis.
This is a serious type
1 hypersensitivity
reaction, an
allergic reaction.
anaphylaxis can
lead to anaphylactic
shock which
can cause death
in the matter of minutes
hypotension
bronchoconstriction death
anaphylactic shock
and it fortunately
it's treatable but
it needs to be very
rapidly treated
airway respiratory
cardiovascular
support, the usual ABC.
Epinephrine,
antihistamines,
glucocorticoids.
Epinephrine,
epinephrine, epinephrine.
We will be studying
epinephrine
in another
couple of months.
This is your
introduction.
Angioedema, this
is a vasculitis of
the deeper vessels
and it can cause
swelling. It can be
life-threatening when
it involves the
airways, the tongue.
Serum sickness, now
this is a type 3 delayed
type reaction. It
can occur days later.
Immunohemolysis,
the hemolytic
anemia I
mentioned before.
Serious rash,
Stevens-Johnson syndrome,
from toxic epidermal
necrolysis, you can
tell by the name,
toxic and
necrolysis and skin.
Fever, interstitial
nephritis,
vasculitis, neutropenia,
thrombocytopenia.
So, certainly
this only happens
to a small
percentage of people,
but millions, millions of
people get antibiotics,
get beta-lactams,
And so we have to be
vigilant and
monitor for it.
Some pictures.
On the left is
this child with
angioedema. You can
see the swollen lips.
And the mucous
membranes on the inside
of the mouth would
be swollen also.
And there can be
swelling in the airways.
urticaria. This
individual in the middle
has this rash all
over her trunk and
on her arms, probably
on her face too.
This is an urticarial
rash. I used a
picture of a light
-skinned person so that
you could really
be able to see it.
And here's Stevens
-Johnson syndrome,
which is a toxic
reaction in the skin.
And this poor person
here, you can see
it all around the
lips. Toxic epidermal
necrolysis is terrible
and involves a
large percentage of
the skin surface.
Well, of course,
the non-aminogenic
side effects tend
to be more frequent.
Diarrhea, I'm not
talking about C.
difficile-associated
diarrhea, just normal
diarrhea that can
occur with antibiotic
therapy and can occur
with most antibiotic
therapy, depending
on the dose and
frequency and the
duration of therapy.
Nausea, vomiting,
the drugs can
cause discomfort
in the stomach.
I talked about
C. difficile
secondary
infection before.
Candidiasis secondary
infection or
yeast infection.
Oral thrush, vaginal
These you do
need to know.
IM injection, it's
kind of painful. Beta
-lactam injection
is into the muscle.
It needs to go
into a deep muscle
injection into the
buttocks. It's painful.
IV injection,
again, it's going to
be irritating to
the tissues, and it
can cause some
vein inflammation,
thrombophlebitis.
this is a picture
of pseudomembranous
colitis here on
the left hand side
you can see the
yellow pseudomembranes
on the wall of the
sigmoid colon that's
because c difficile
produces toxins toxin
a and toxin b which
are cytolytic and
c difficile here by
electron microscope.
This is a gram
-positive rod,
spore forming,
and here it is
growing on a
blood auger plate.
Picture of oral
candidiasis here
on the tongue,
and a picture of
phlebitis on the
arm of this patient.
And arachnoiditis
is inflammation
of the arachnoid
membranes, layers.
Pregnancy, well, we
always have to think
if I have a pregnant
patient, am I going to
be able to give the
drug? And the great
thing about the beta
-lactams is it's generally
compatible with
pregnancy. No evidence
of impaired fertility,
of fetal harm, and
the mother is not at
increased risk for
adverse events, and
neither is the fetus.
Lactation, it may be
excreted in breast milk.
When that happens,
we have to think
about the baby taking
in antibiotic during
nursing, and that could
cause modifications
in the bowel
flora. So diarrhea,
just from getting the
antibiotic in
the breast milk.
For pediatrics, we
also have to think
about, are there
recommendations
for dosing in the
pediatric patient?
Pediatric patients
are not little adults.
They have their
own pharmacokinetic
profiles. So we
need to have the
information in order
to safely administer
the drugs to infants
and children.
And fortunately,
most of the beta
-lactams are safe
for neonates.
Takeaway.
Please remember,
neonates have
immature functions.
Functions. Immature
renal function in
relation to the beta
-lactams because the
beta-lactams are
excreted unchanged.
They also have immature
liver functions.
Immature drug
metabolizing functions.
drug interactions.
I'm just going to focus
on a couple of them.
Probenicid is
actually used in
combination for
a beneficial
drug interaction
with penicillin.
Penicillin G.
Because it inhibits
the organic anion
transporter in the
proximal tubule that will
block or I should say
slow the secretion
of the beta-lactam
through that organic
anion transporter that
will in turn increase
plasma levels and
duration of therapy.
Not widely used, but
it is sometimes used.
Penicillin G is
really short-acting.
Methotrexate is used in
rheumatoid arthritis.
It's also a cancer
drug, and it's highly
toxic with a narrow
therapeutic window.
Warfarin,
commonly used
anticoagulant,
less commonly than
it used to be,
but it's still
commonly used.
So anticoagulants,
think bleeding.
But I'm not going to
ask you to remember
warfarin or mesotrexate.
I am asking you
to remember probenicid
because it's used
together with the
penicillin. I want you
to remember about
hormonal contraception
because estrogen
undergoes
enterohepatic
circulation. It gets
a glucuronide
in the liver,
enterohepatic circulation,
travels through
the gut, that beta
-lactam, sorry, the
glucuronide is cleaved
by gut bacteria and
the estrogen gets
reabsorbed. So if we are
killing gut bacteria,
including those that
cleave the beta-lac,
I keep saying that,
cleave the
glucuronide off of the
estrogen, then that's
not going to happen.
The estrogen will not
be reabsorbed. that
will decrease estrogen
levels that can
decrease oral contraceptive
efficacy and that
may increase pregnancy
risk now studies
have shown that this
is not such a big
deal as one would think
but it occurs to me
that if even one
person becomes pregnant
who didn't wish to be
pregnant because of
the antibiotic therapy
and because we didn't
caution that patient
then shame on us.
Proton pump inhibitors
increase the risk
of C difficile I'm
not going to ask
you to memorize that
for right now but you
will need to know
that at some point.
Tetracyclines this
is another antibiotic
and it has been shown
to decrease penicillin
efficacy when used
together with it.
And any kind of
vaccine that's live
attenuated bacteria,
well, an antibiotic
is going to
inactivate it. So
the ones I want
you to remember are
probenicid, you can
put a star on it,
the oral
contraceptives, and
tetracycline. So
put a star on those.
So check your knowledge.
This is a list.
But in the interest
of time, I'm not
going to go over
these questions. I
suggest you pause
your computer and
see if you can
remember the answers
without looking.
I have a list at
the very end of the
PowerPoint that has
the answers on it.
So let's talk about
beta-lactamases. I'm
going to start with
these because we have
drugs that inhibit
the beta-lactamases.
And these drugs are
used with a variety
of different beta
-lactam drugs. So it's
helpful to have the
information in advance.
So this Ambler
classification scheme,
it's not the only
way to do it,
classifies them
as A, B, C, and D.
The class A are
called, I should say
that beta-lactamases
within the class
A are called the
extended-spectrum beta
-lactamases, ESBLs,
highly prevalent.
They derive from
the TEM, SHV,
and CTX-M, and
they are resistant
to most of the
beta-lactamases.
I'm sorry, beta
-lactam drugs,
so how important is that?
And then the KPC
carbapenemase, well,
carbapenems are our
powerhouse, beta-lactams.
And if we lose their
activity because of
these beta-lactamases
expressed by
Klebsiella, this is
Klebsiella pneumoniae
carbapenemase, then we
lose the whole group.
And this is such an
important class of drugs.
Now, our beta-lactamase
inhibitors, hurrah,
prevent the actions
of these beta
-lactamases, or at least
most of them, anyway.
I have A, C, and
D on this list, in
this order, because
these are all these
so-called serine
beta-lactamases.
I am focusing on
the class A and
class C, because
these are prevalent.
Class C is called AMP-C.
That's the one I want
you to remember. AMP-C,
of course, the ESBLs,
these guys, and the KPCs.
Because the
organisms that
express AMP-C
beta-lactamases
are resistant to
such a number of beta
-lactam antibiotics.
So these are multi
-drug resistant, and
that's called MDR.
Now, class B, I'm
also focusing on.
They have a zinc
in them, so they're
metallobeta
-lactamases. These are
not inhibited by
beta-lactamase
inhibitors. That's
the takeaway. Anyway,
class B metallobeta
-lactamases
expressed by a number
of gram-negative
bacilli are just
resistant to
beta-lactams. The
end of the story.
So class A, class C,
amp C, and metallos.
so see the
pattern get the
basics look for
the patterns
these are the beta
-lactamase inhibitors
these three have been
around for a long time
these are the most
recent additions
and I have stars
on all of them
because they're
that important
the original ones
have a beta-lactam
structure these
are irreversible
see how similar it
is and these are
reversible and they
don't have a beta
-lactam structure
and they're potent
and the AI came
up with a mnemonic
device if you
care to use it
The antibacterial
spectrum is
determined by the beta
-lactam antibiotic,
not the beta
-lactamase inhibitor.
If an organism
would be susceptible
in the ideal world of
susceptibility to
a particular drug,
and now isn't because
of beta-lactamase
expression, then
the beta-lactamase
inhibitor will return
the activity to the beta
-lactam. But if it
never was effective
in the first place,
the beta-lactamase
inhibitor won't allow
it to be effective.
Beta-lactamase inhibitors
have weak antibacterial
activity on their
own, virtually useless
as an antibacterial
with one exception.
And I put the exception
down here. You do
not need to memorize
this. This is just
information for context.
It will come up at some
point in the future,
and you should know
it then, but you don't
need to know it now.
So the original
three clavulanic
acid, solbactin, and
tazabactin inhibit
Hambler class A
beta-lactamases.
So that includes
those ESBLs.
and the second
group, the avibactum,
vabrabactum, relabactum,
and duralabactum,
are potent and
reversible.
They are reversible,
but they're so potent
they really hang
on for a long time.
And these inhibit
class A and class C.
All right, so I have a
chart here to help you.
The irreversible
are on the top.
Well, basically, they
all inhibit class
A. That's what you
need to remember.
The original three don't
inhibit anything else.
None of them inhibits the
class B
metallobatolactamases.
You see the pattern?
And then the
second group,
the potent
reversible types,
inhibit a good
percentage of the
KPC carbapenemases.
Thank goodness.
So we get the
activity of the drugs
back by adding one
of these malactamase
inhibitors to the
therapy. And then a
couple of them also
are effective against
class D. I don't
want to get involved
with that right
now. It's important
but you have enough
to know for now.
Here are some
questions. I invite you
to pause the video
and think about
them. I'm not going
to go over them
in the interest of
time and the answers
are at the end of
this PowerPoint.
Let's take a look at the
penicillins class.
These are the
natural penicillins,
penicillin G,
the penicillinase
resistant penicillins,
the amino
penicillins, and the
antepseudomonal
penicillins. So these groups
are also called
extended spectrum.
And these are
narrow spectrum.
And we'll see
why in a moment.
Natural penicillins,
this is their
spectrum of
activity. This is
the spectrum of
activity of the
penicillinase
-resistant penicillins.
This is the
spectrum of activity
of the
aminopenicillins and
the antepseudamonal
penicillins.
So let's look at
them one by one.
So the penicillins
are a narrow spectrum
of action. And I've
put a gray box over the
organisms that are
not susceptible to
penicillin. So let's look
at what is susceptible
and see why penicillin
is considered
narrow spectrum. So,
gram-positive, all good,
generally,
and spirochetes, gram
-positive and spirochetes.
Ah,
one gram-negative,
the one that causes
meningitis, Neisseria
meningitidis.
Naturally, C. difficile
is not susceptible.
The double line
through these means
they have been
susceptible at one time.
Staphylococcus now,
virtually all of them
express penicillinase,
so they're no
longer susceptible.
And Enterococcus
faecium is a pretty
difficult bug to
treat, period.
Enterococcus, penicillin
is actually
bacteriostatic.
So I said these are
bactericidal drugs
most of the time.
This is an exception.
So that's it, a
narrow spectrum.
Gram positive, good.
Spirochetes,
treponema paladin,
what are we thinking
of here? ********.
So ********, good,
and Neisseria
meningitidis,
meningitis, good.
That's it.
Pharmacokinetics,
what I want to point
out right here is
Pen-G is IV and IM.
It has really poor
oral absorption.
Penicillin V is
oral only, and it
was formed from
penicillin G to
be more acid-stable.
You still have
to take it on an
empty stomach.
And then we have
this repository
intramuscular injection.
And the long-acting
one, which is
what we see here,
is for ********.
one dose will last
two to three weeks so
i mentioned before
staph aureus expresses
penicillinase gram
negative bacilli express
various beta-lactamases
plus penicillin
can't pass through the
porins streptococcus
pneumoniae i do want
you to know these has
an alteration in the
penicillin-binding
protein. Methicillin
-resistant, same thing.
Enterococcus
faecium, same thing.
Also, Enterococcus
faecalis to some extent.
So, Streptococcus
pneumoniae,
MRSA,
Enterococcus, PBP.
If there is a
PBP alteration,
target alteration,
then no beta-lactam
is going to work.
Of course, there
are exceptions.
Intrinsic resistance,
gram-negative, because
the penicillins can't
pass through, with
the exception of the
Neisserium energiditis.
Hypersensitivity
reactions,
we talked about that.
Penicillins are
also CNS irritants.
They can cause
seizures in high doses.
So penicillin does
not readily cross
the blood-brain
barrier. except when
the meninges are
inflamed. So seizures
is not going to be
normally a problem.
Electrolyte
disturbance is not from
the penicillin, but
because it's formulated
with sodium and
potassium salts.
And because the drug
has a short half
-life and it's given
many times during
the day, even by
continuous infusion,
then the patient can
be receiving quite
a bit of sodium and
or potassium. So
the electrolytes
have to be watched.
And this Jarish
-Herxheimer reaction, this
is ********. The boards
love this question.
Penicillin is
really effective
against treponema
paladin,
and the treatment
is ********.
And these
spirochetes die, and
they draw an
immune reaction.
So it's an acute
self-limited febrile
reaction because
of the antibiotic
treatment and the
exposure of the immune
system to these
dying spirochetes.
Now let's take a look
at the second group.
This is the second
group to have been
developed. I mentioned
that Staphylococcus
aureus rapidly
developed penicillinase
and was therefore
resistant to penicillin
G. So what do we
do? Ah, we need to
develop drugs that are
going to be effective
against that penicillin
-age-producing
organism. And we have
three of them now.
Methicillin was
the first one
in this group
to be developed.
Hence, we hear
about methicillin
-sensitive, staph aureus,
methicillin-resistant,
staph aureus.
Methicillin is no
longer available.
It was just drawn
decades ago.
because it caused
a relatively high
incidence of
interstitial nephritis.
But these other ones
were developed instead,
and they are used
to treat methicillin
-sensitive
Staphylococcus aureus,
or Staphylococcus
epidermidis.
Oxacillin is
actually oral,
but dicloxacillin
is used far more
frequently because of
better absorption so
here's the spectrum
of activity nearly
everything is blocked
out so what isn't blocked
out the gram positive
cocci streptococcus
group a methicillin
sensitive staph aureus
and methicillin sensitive
staph epidermidis
now if a patient has
these infections and
that a different drug
is going to be used
because they're more
effective than this one
so basically the
spectrum of activity is
this that's pretty
narrow spectrum if the
methicillin I'm sorry
if the staphylococcus
expresses resistance
by altered penicillin
binding proteins these
drugs will not work.
Now the difference
in pharmacokinetics
compared to the class
effects is hepatic
elimination, non
-renal elimination.
So no dosage
adjustment is necessary
for renal impairment
with these drugs.
I mentioned the activity.
MSSA, yes. MRSA, no.
The penicillin
-binding protein 2A
expressed by MEK-A
gene has very low
affinity for beta
-lactams. The boards
love this piece
of information.
Therapeutic use.
Methicillin
-sensitive staph.
Adverse effects. They
could cause hepatitis.
Remember, they're
excreted via the liver.
And this acute
interstitial nephritis
that methicillin was
associated with occurs
really only rarely
with these drugs.
Doesn't mean we
don't watch for it.
Now the extended
spectrum penicillins, a
very, very important
group of drugs. These
are the aminopenicillins.
And their
structure was developed
so that they can
actually pass through
the porins and get to
the PBPs within gram
-negative organisms. So
they have a much better
spectrum of activity
than we saw with
their predecessors.
They are also
combined with a beta
-lactamase inhibitor.
So they can
be acquired either
with or without
the beta-lactamase
inhibitors.
And way fewer
organisms are blocked
out when we look
at the amino
penicillin spectrum
of activity.
Again, the double
strike-through are
organisms that have
developed considerable
resistance, but
the beta-lactamase
inhibitor returns
the susceptibility.
Basically, that's
what I just said.
So what is the
spectrum? Same as
penicillin plus
some respiratory
pathogens, so those
are gram negatives,
plus some aerobic gram
-negative bacteria,
such as the gut bugs,
the enterobacteriales,
and other gram
-negative bacteria.
What else do I
want to say here?
Oh, Pseudomonas is
resistant. Pseudomonas
is this little obligate
aerobe organism
that can cause serious,
serious infection
in immunocompromised
people. People die
from this. Ventilator
-associated pneumonia.
Serious, complicated
urinary tract infections.
And others.
Bacteremia.
and so we're not
going to be using
any of the drugs
we already saw
for the treatment
of Pseudomonas.
Something very
important to remember
about the aminopenicillins,
ampicillin, and
amoxicillin is this
non-allergic rash.
It's a maculopapular
rash on the trunk and
it can spread to
the face. It usually
is delayed in appearance.
It doesn't appear
for even up to a week
and in some cases
even longer than that
a couple of weeks.
And so what causes
it? Well it appears to
be associated when
the amino penicillin
particularly amoxicillin
or ampicillin
is given to a patient
who has a viral
infection such as
roseola, or mononucleosis.
So why are we
giving it to a
patient with a
viral infection? We
shouldn't be
doing that at all.
And there's a drug
interaction. When
it's given to patients
who take allopurinol,
allopurinol is
for gout, that
reaction can cause
this non-allergic rash.
That said, it can
also cause allergic
rashes. And these
usually occur rapidly.
Ampicillin, I am IV oral,
amoxicillin oral only.
Chances are you've
had amoxicillin or
amoxicillin clavulanate
when you were a
child for the
treatment of some upper
respiratory infection
like otitis media.
The drugs are
equivalent in spectrum.
The main difference
is that amoxicillin
has this great oral
bioavailability.
As a result, compared
to oral ampicillin,
the plasma levels
are much higher.
Drug is not metabolized.
It's pretty typical
of the class beta
-lactam pharmacokinetics.
High concentrations
excreted
in urine, so it
would be good
for urinary
tract infections.
unabsorbed oral
ampicillin will pass
through the gut and
it will act on the
microbiota in the
gut and kill them. So
we can see C. difficile
associated diarrhea
in patients who
have C. difficile.
And it's got a
short half-life.
Okay now I mentioned
that the drugs we
had seen thus far are
not useful against
pseudomonas. Well,
this particular drug,
pipericillin
-tazobactam, which is the
only one in this
group that's available
any longer, is effective
against pseudomonas.
So it's got the
same spectrum of
action as the ampicillin,
but it includes
pseudomonas
susceptibility.
It's called a
uretopenicillin. I'm
not asking you to
memorize that, but
you will hear it
and you will see it.
Now look at this
spectrum of action.
You can see why it's
called, piperacillin
tazabactam is
called the most
powerful drug in the
penicillins class.
It has the
greatest spectrum
of activity. It's easy to
remember what is
not susceptible,
then remembering
what is susceptible.
So the big takeaway is
pseudomonas and
broad spectrum.
Therapeutic use is a wide
gamut of serious
infections.
It also has
sodium salt in
it and a short half-life.
It can cause some
bleeding disorders,
seizure disorders,
just like
penicillin, with
the high doses,
and patients with
renal impairment,
because then the plasma
levels are higher.
Leukopenia,
not neutropenia
with long-term use.
And some more questions.
Again, I won't go
over them. The answers
are at the end.
I encourage you
to pause the video
and see if you can
remember the answers
without looking.
And a summary,
very quickly.
Beta-lactam ring for
activity. PBPs
is the target.
PBP is caused a
cross-linking.
Bacterial autolysins
are triggered causing
osmotic rupture of
the cell and non-lytic
mechanisms are
probably also involved.
The organisms must
be synthesizing cell
walls so they need
to be proliferating.
The antibacterial
spectrum is determined
by the drug's ability
to access the PBPs.
So penicillins can't
get through the porins
so they don't access
them with the one
exception, Neisseria
meningitidis. And
through the list we
see greater activity
based on the structures
and the ability of
the extended spectrum
penicillins to reach
the target in gram
-negative organisms.
I'm not going to
go over this. I
encourage you to
read it on your own.
This just is a review
of the spectrums of
activity of the various
penicillins group.
And our beta-lactamase
inhibitor is the
clavulanic acid,
sulbactin, tazobactin,
irreversible group,
the early group,
avibactin, relabactin,
fabrobactin. Drillabactin
are the potent
reversible inhibitors
that were developed a
little sometime later.
And the Ambler
classification,
the drugs that I
want, the bugs I
want you to know
by name, and the
biolactamase inhibitors
that are useful
in returning the
activity of the drug
to fight against
these infections.
And here are the answers,
and this is a nice
picture, and our
references. And that
That concludes part
one of the beta
-lactam antibiotics.